con nuestro primer invitado al día
hablamos del mundial de Qatar y las
denuncias de abusos laborales a la
población migrante porque pese a las
reformas gubernamentales esta población
continua sufriendo abusos laborales y
teniendo dificultades para cambiar de
empleo libremente cuando ellos lo
quisieran estas restricciones a la
libertad de expresión aumentaron en el
período previo a la Copa del Mundo de la
FIFA 2022 las mujeres y las personas
lgbti también continuaron sufriendo
discriminación en esta en la ley también
en la práctica mucho caos mucha polémica
no en torno a este mundial de Qatar 2022
que inicia en noviembre y lo vamos a
hablar con Carlos de las eras experto en
deportes y en derechos humanos de
amnistía internacional España Carlos
Gracias por estar nuevamente con
nosotros en directo América de Francia
24 pongamos en contexto el tema primero
hablemos de esta situación laboral sobre
todo para la población migrante en en
Qatar no de al mundial y todas las
anuncias que hemos conocido a lo largo
de estos meses
Sí bueno en primer lugar Muchas gracias
Buen día para todos para todas desde
amnistía internacional llevamos desde
que se concedió la organización de la
Copa del Mundo del mundial de fútbol
acatar allá por el año 2010 pues
denunciando la situación de miles de
trabajadores y de trabajadoras migrantes
cuyos derechos laborales no han sido y
aún a día de hoy todavía no están siendo
respetados en el país todo esto parte
del sistema laboral catari lo que se
llama el sistema de cafala un sistema
mediante el cual el empresario o el
empleador pues puede llegar a tener un
control prácticamente total sobre la
sobre la vida de las personas empleadas
afortunadamente en los últimos años y
tras múltiples denuncias este sistema de
cafalas está reformando y ha habido
pequeños avances Pero estas reformas que
están recogidas en la ley catari todavía
no se están poniendo en práctica de la
manera que deberían de ponerse en
práctica es decir al cien garante con
los derechos los trabajadores y las
trabajadoras Sabiendo todo este panorama
de derechos laborales y también humanos
Por qué la FIFA escogió
Qatar para que se desarrolle se celebre
esta Copa Mundial ya varios países
también por ejemplo varias ciudades en
Francia han dicho que van a boicotear
digamos estos juegos o no poniéndolos en
pantallas gigantes en varias ciudades
como lo es habitual en estas copas del
mundo a lo que voy a la pregunta
original Por qué Qatar teniendo todo
este contexto no
Esto es algo a lo que llevamos
asistiendo también
desde hace varios años no solo en el
caso de catar sino de muchísimos países
que están utilizando este tipo de
eventos como la Copa del Mundo de fútbol
juegos olímpicos mundial de Fórmula 1
etcétera etcétera para ofrecer al mundo
una imagen abierta moderna reformista
cuando la realidad es muy diferente la
realidad es que los Derechos Humanos
pues no están siendo respetados esto se
llama como se conoce como blanqueo
deportivo o Sports washing y es una de
las tácticas que países como en este
caso Qatar está poniendo en marcha para
como decía ofrecer al mundo una imagen
que realmente poco tiene que ver con la
realidad de estos países y además catar
es que no es un país por excelencia de
tradición futbolística no Carlos
hablemos o precisamente también de lo
que va a pasar con minorías que
evidentemente van a llegar a Qatar para
disfrutar de esta Copa del Mundo
hablamos sobre todo de la lgbti en un
país tan con como Qatar con unas leyes
tan restrictivas donde la homosexualidad
también está digamos punitiva en la ley
Cómo van a hacer no los organizadores
para proteger a estas a personas que
tienen todo el derecho del mundo de
evidentemente disfrutar una copa del
mundo pero pues es sin ser perseguidas
no también han escuchado hemos escuchado
denuncias de que en algunos hoteles
estaba prohibido que dos personas del
mismo sexo digamos pareja reserva una
habitación de hotel
sí Esto es así con determinados
colectivos Como por ejemplo las personas
lgbti
el llamamiento es muy sencillo igual que
en cualquier otro país evidentemente hay
que respetar las costumbres locales hay
que respetar la ley local pero hay que
conocerla y las personas que viajen a
Qatar todas las personas que viajan a
Qatar deben de saber que hay algún tipos
algunos tipos de restricciones y que por
ejemplo la homosexualidad está como tú
decías incluso penada con castigada con
penas de cárcel que pueden llegar a 7 a
entre 7 y 10 años con lo cual bueno es
algo que confiamos que la organización
que en tanto FIFA como las autoridades
cataríes en este sentido vayan a ser
garantes de la libertad de expresión de
todas las personas pero es algo que
tenemos que conocer y que en un momento
dado tenemos que acatar
también en las mujeres se verían digamos
un poco en peligro si se puede decir de
de esa manera en Qatar también en los
códigos de vestimenta haciendo un país
musulmán Cuál va a ser la situación de
las mujeres y cómo se puede proteger
Exacto en general en Qatar las mujeres
también están sometidas a distintos
abusos abusos que tienen su origen o su
raíz en lo que se llama el sistema de
tutela masculina un sistema mediante el
cual un pariente varón normalmente el
padre el esposo o algún familiar
directamente cercano Como por ejemplo un
hermano pues tienen privilegios sobre
los derechos de las mujeres es decir
pueden aceptar o no distintas códigos de
vestimenta como decías
lugares a los que pueden o no pueden
asistir permiso incluso para por ejemplo
poder salir del país sin esta
autorización por parte del familiar
varón etcétera etcétera con las mujeres
extranjeras que viajen en Qatar este
sistema de tutela masculina
evidentemente no es no está activado No
no es no es algo que vaya a funcionar
pero por ejemplo en cuanto a códigos de
vestimenta etcétera etcétera Pues al
igual que si viajáramos a otro país
donde las leyes marcaran unos códigos de
vestimenta pues deben de ser respetados
y acatados por supuesto estas
diferencias culturales hay que tenerlas
en cuenta y hay que y hay que
respetarlas Carlos ya para para terminar
de subir un poco nuestra conversación
los derechos fundamentales de las
personas se verían amenazados en esta
fiesta del mundo realmente están
blindadas
blindadas las autoridades
internacionales para poder actuar para
poder proteger a estas personas la
diversidad que se ve en cualquier época
del mundo en un país occidental por
ejemplo
Bueno ahí el papel fundamental
evidentemente las autoridades primero
cataríes Y en segundo lugar las
autoridades internacionales de cualquier
país que vaya a enviar o a permitir a
facilitar Mejor dicho el viaje de sus
aficionados y sus aficionados acatar
para disfrutar del mundial
es importante tenerla en cuenta pero
también tenemos que hablar O estaría
bien finalizada hablando del papel que
tiene que jugar Fifa que realmente es
quien organiza este mundial en Qatar y
quien también tiene una responsabilidad
es por sus acciones subsidiarias en este
país FIFA debe de garantizar que todas
las personas que acudan a ver los
partidos del Mundial ven respetados sus
derechos derechos Como por ejemplo la
libertad de expresión es decir nadie
podría o debería de ser perseguido por
expresarse libremente y aquí hablo pues
por ejemplo de banderas arcoiris o
demostrar afecto en público o de llevar
a cabo pues cualquier tipo de acto de
libertad de expresión que en todo el
mundo debe de ser respetada y también en
Qatar Carlos Gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros esta mañana de
miércoles en directo América un abrazo
un abrazo Muchas gracias a